comme on a vu dans le reportage ceux qui
sont évacués en ce moment dans les
trains d'évacuation pour la plupart ce
sont des gens qui avaient décidé de
rester qu'ils étaient bien déterminés à
rester pour plusieurs raisons souvent ce
sont les gens les plus démunis les plus
pauvres qui sont restés aussi parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas où aller et c'est
maintenant à cause des bombardements
vraiment très intense qu'ils ont compris
que vraiment il l'était le moment de
partir tous ceux à qui on a parlé on dit
que les bombardements sont devenus
vraiment beaucoup plus intense ces
derniers jours pour une grande partie
d'entre eux leurs propres maisons ont
été touchées mais les volontaires qui
vont les chercher avec ses mini bus nous
disent qu'ils ont tout de même souvent
du mal à convaincre les gens de quitter
leur maison et ils sont obligés de leur
dire que c'est vraiment le moment ou
jamais on n'est pas sûr de pouvoir
revenir une autre fois pour venir vous
chercher et c'est bien le cas en ce
moment il y à des localités où les
travailleurs volontaires les ong ne
peuvent tout simplement pas y aller les
militaires ukrainien ne leur laisse pas
l'accès à ces localités parce que c'est
juste trop dangereux par exemple assez
verrou donetsk il est très très très
difficile en ce moment d'organiser des
évacuations et les autorités
ukrainiennes implorent les civils en
fait de profiter de toute possibilité
d'évacuer s'il y en a une pour leur
propre sécurité mais aussi parce que
pour l'armée ukrainienne il est beaucoup
plus facile de mener le combat s'il n'y
a pas de civils s'ils ne sont pas
obligés en même temps de protéger les
civils alors il ya vraiment une
politique en ce moment d'évacuation de
ces endroits